I think taking the surprise kill out Oh
the main reason was we did have many
interactions with his female and after
we took the Buffalo birth out the
surprise kill with his newborn baby
seemed that it was another one that we
should take out and also a lot of people
seemed very traumatized there was a
newborn calf which basically for us on
the day filming it we were pretty
emotionally traumatized ourselves I can
understand why they felt that way but it
is massively shot the way Jarek managed
to capture that female coming in and it
is a total surprise to everybody what I
really like probably nothing to do with
me but a moment ago there was a
butterfly that had been through the
frame and I always always looked at the
Buffalo again wow what a symbol of
innocence as it go through yeah anyway
it came out and we always refer to that
as a surprise kill because they'd pan
back into the into the greenery behind
and what happens is you'll often find
that the herd will come back as soon as
they're here an animal in distress and
especially the female that is just given
birth she comes back and chill often try
and challenge the lioness or the pride
and often that is works to her
disadvantage because if the pride is
there they will bring her down as well
one of my favorite shots are actually
merciless blood and gore because it
really does epitomize what predators are
without apologizing from